hello everyone well the title says it
all really this is just a nice routine
of game to write in your day so
recognize matheno is playing white and
he's playing against you record cough
and as much as I tried to research this
guy cod Cove I couldn't find any
information whatsoever about him on the
Internet
other than the game was played in 1957
in cross-gender Russia and the reason is
I said I decided to show this game well
it has well entertaining values as well
as educational rush it really shows how
to play a game when you're ahead in
development so let's see the game
Rashida is white and he plays d4 we had
b5 by Coco Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Russia plays Bishop to b5 the reuleaux
PES so we have Knight to f6 the Berlin
defense and we have castles by Rashida
Knight to e4 rook to e1 and nine to d6
and here wash it captures Knight
captures any 5 we have Bishop to e7 and
now a they should be back to D 3 by
Rasheed so black castles we have Knight
to c3 Knight captures on e5 rook
captures an e5 and now Bishop to f6 and
this kind of reminds you of the Marshall
gambit accepted the knight and the
bishop have switched places so where she
plays rook to e3
we have g6 by cold cough going to f3
attacking the bishop so the bishop is
put away to g7 and we have b3 by Rasheed
so cost of plays Knight back to e8 and
where he plays Bishop to e3 attacking
the rook Rasheed doesn't think twice
about developing the piece with a tempo
so we have these six by Coco truck 81
doubling up on the e-file and now we
have Knight to f6 and this is well
preparing to develop the light-square
bishop here to g4 attacking the Queen's
overheat stops if he plays h3 and now we
have a nice to d7 by Coco he gets the
idea that he would like to capture this
knight on c3 because this bishop is kind
of blossomed is the upon from developing
but if you look at this position well
Rashida already has all of his pieces
developed to look at this both of the
roofs are very nicely placed on the
e-file both of the bishops are eyeing
the black King G
the Queen's developed the night is
developed and Costco has already played
six moves with this night putting at 37
and well it's only move 15 so Russia
doesn't allow this of course he played
knighted Knight to d5 and this is a this
is a very nice position for white so
what Russia did with this 95 move is
actually preventing black from playing
something like b7 if he plays b7 and
simply Knight to e7 check will pick up
the rook and you can replace this six
keep the night away from there because
97 again it's checking the black King
will pick up the d6 pawn so it's a
extremely hard to find out move for
black you could play something like rook
to b8 simply to get this rook out of the
Queen's way but that's too slow of a
move to play against someone like Rashid
so black tries an active movement he
plays that five and in this position
well there are a lot of good news Weiss
can play something like rook to e7
simply owning black position if you
could play something like Bishop to c4
he could play Queen to f4 simply
improving the position and really going
for this d6 pawn and rushing finds an
even faster way to win this and what's
interesting about Rasheed's next move is
that the engine dislikes it the engine
doesn't think it's a good move and
rushing plays Knight casters in c7 and
this is well you can't really refuse
this offering because if you refuse by
playing something like rook to b8 you
get a nice to e6 and this is affecting
the Queen and the rook
so after Knight to c6 you kind of do
have to capture the night
so King captures on c7 is played and
here where she plays Queen to d5 check
so the black King has to move to h8 and
now Rashid plays rook to e8 and it's
funny as it usually is in the games of
Michael Tala and Rashida Schmidt you
know the computer dislikes their move at
a certain point but a couple of moves
later the computer really loves their
position position so after rook to e8
the computer actually agrees yeah this
is a very good move and it was a good
idea so here we have
Knight to f6 by Costco attacking the
White Queen so Rashid captures and I say
rook captures on f8 Bishop captures an F
8 and now Rashid plays Bishop to b2
pinning this Knight
so this Knight cannot move so cost of
Defense at Bishop to g7 and now Rashid
finds a very nice Rashid move he plays
Bishop to c4 offering the Queen but of
course the Queen can be captured if the
queen is captured then simply rook to e8
with the instance checkmate so after
Bishop to c4 he tried Bishop to d7
simply allowing this rook to control the
last rank and in here where she played
Bishop captures an f6
the bishop captures an f6 and now Queen
to f7 now the Queen is attacking this
Bishop and well cod Cove in this move he
plays Queen to d8 to somehow protect
this Bishop from certain doom and well
Rashida finishes the game in a very nice
blow he plays rook to e8 check and this
is game over instantly because whatever
black plays it's game over if if the
Queen captures the rook then simply
Queen captures Bishop on a stick this is
instant checkmate and if the Bishop
captures Rockwell then the Queen is no
longer controlling the last rank and
simply Queen to f8 is again instant
checkmate so yeah a very nice game by
nature matino
and well like I said I just wanted to
show a very nice miniature by the
Trentino as I said I will return to
management enum series so that's it for
this game I do hope you enjoyed it and
like I said I couldn't find any
information whatsoever about this code
code guy I don't know if he's an
international natural Grandmaster or
anything so if any of you have any idea
who he was
please do share in the comments and as
usual even talked to my previous videos
here and yeah that's it for this video
thank you all for watching and I'll see
you soon